I want to bring together some separate
bits of news on immigration policy and
show you what it adds up to because I
think it's a really big deal and it was
all happening this week first the wall
after all that fuss all those dramas
government shutdowns whatever we learned
this week that guess what the wall is
being built 60 miles already done and
between 450 and 500 by the end of next
year as always when we talk immigration
I'll start by saying I am Pro
immigration I am an immigrant myself
twice over my parents to Hungary and now
me here to America where as I mentioned
a couple of months ago I hope I'll soon
be a citizen I think the vast majority
of Americans are Pro immigration as long
as it is properly controlled and I think
the vast majority of Americans are
compassionate people who also want to
give sanctuary to refugees fleeing
persecution as long as that is authentic
and by the way that goes for the vast
majority of Trump supporters decent
people who just want the best for their
country and are sick of being smeared as
racist for supporting immigration
policies which let me remind you were
once widely held by Democrats
let's pick I don't know a couple of
random Democrats how about Joe Biden and
Chuck Schumer in the case of Joe Biden
very random illegal immigration is wrong
plain and simple
until the American people are convinced
that we will stop future flows of
illegal immigration we will make no
progress on dealing with the millions of
illegal immigrants who are here now and
on rationalizing our system of legal
immigration it's plain and simple and
unavoidable who could possibly disagree
with that oh we can't wall ourselves off
from the problems that are not bound by
borders the threat of communicable
disease is like Zika drug trafficking
climate change no wall can be built it
is a shame that this president who is
plunging the nation in decay
he's throwing another temper tantrum and
gonna hurt lots of innocent people the
Trump temper tantrum may produce a
government shutdown it will not get him
his wal Biden says no wall can be built
of course immoral except both of them
voted for the 2006 secure Fence Act
which actually had more money in it for
more wall than even President Trump is
building whatever the issue whatever the
facts of trumps for it they're against
it regardless of their previous use what
a bunch of total charlatans these
Democrats are is the same idiocy with
asylum the president and his team scored
a major victory in the Supreme Court
this week which lifted an injunction on
a new rule which requires asylum seekers
to claim asylum in the first safe
country they come to rather than travel
through countries because they want to
get to America and claim asylum here
predictably the Democrats lost their
minds Nancy Pelosi releasing a totally
deranged and factually inaccurate
statement including this quote the
Supreme Court's decision to allow the
Trump administration to inflict it's
cruel new Asylum policy on the world's
most vulnerable populations at the
southern border is deeply disappointing
profoundly dangerous and a clear
departure from both US and international
law these people are so ridiculous it's
not a departure from international law
it brings us in line with international
law do they even know that this new
Trump asylum policy is basically the
same as the --use look there's a
difference between Asylum and migration
of course people want to come to America
is the greatest place in the world but
you've got to have an orderly process
public consent for immigration depends
on government control of immigration we
haven't had that here since at least
1986 when President Reagan signed the
disastrous immigration reform and
Control Act which did by the way the
exact opposite of that El Salvador
Honduras and Guatemala are democracies
not dictatorships what Amala just voted
in a new president
the Democrats and the establishment say
those countries are corrupt well yes
they are but not as corrupt as
Washington where Vice President Biden
took over a billion dollars in bribes
from the Chinese government in the form
of payments to Biden family businesses
or where Vice President Dick Cheney
engineered a war that funneled billions
of dollars to the company where he was
CEO or where members of Congress are
funded by the exact same businesses they
regulate we'll be talking about that
particular scandal later in the show the
asylum seekers are fleeing crime and
gang violence we're told yes they are
but guess what those same gangs are here
the Democrats and the establishment
state media have totally lost the plot
on immigration that's because they've
lost touch with working Americans it's
not their jobs being lost it's not their
incomes going down it's not their kids
schools being overwhelmed by contrast
the Trump administration is finally
putting together the reasonable coherent
immigration policy this country has been
crying out for for nearly 50 years we
see it with a wall going up but it's
much more than that in many ways it's
five walls the physical one but also the
legal one with the asylum change a
technology wall and entitlement reform
wall to help reduce incentives and a
foreign policy war to encourage other
countries to do more as we saw with
immediate results with Mexico and the
tariffs threat on top of all that and
totally contradicting the establishment
lie that this is a xenophobic
restriction asti's a walls as the saying
goes with a door months ago the
president announced a plan not to cut
legal immigration but to keep it at
present levels instead reforming it to
become a merit-based system all of this
is utterly reasonable and in line with
mainstream opinion in this country the
Democrats lurch to the open borders left
is the real extremist position on
immigration today tell me what you think
of all that that Steve Hilton X and at
an extra FNC right who wants to kick us
off loudly say this the most important
situation that happened over the last
week was the Supreme Court's decision on
asylum it does so more so
much more than what had happened in the
past like it building the wall is just
part of that infrastructure to try to
stop illegal immigration the asylum law
being able to enforce that as a
deterrent I've been there so many times
Steve I was in Guatemala twice this last
year I've been on the border and I know
what's going on there the drug cartels
and the human traffickers use these
Asylum laws to bring more and more
people in they're not fleeing gangs a
lot of them are coming here for jobs for
better job offerings some of them know
some of them are but but let me be fair
to I was in Guatemala and I was in a lot
of these different villages and I was
talking to the Guatemalan government and
I was there on the ground there are
issues with gangs there are issues with
gangs here but the majority of people
were fleeing economic poverty they were
coming to the United States and they
were told they were actually rehearsing
on the way to the border what they would
need to say to get into the United
States say that you're fleeing gangs say
that you're part of a domestic violence
tell them that you can't return for
political reasons and then we saw it
spread to the children bring your
children in and you'll get safe harbor
in the United States then we saw it go
outside of Central America to Africa and
to other nations where people were
saying look if we make these same
conditions meet these same conditions to
enter the United States we'll be able to
get in and that is a huge problem and it
is a national security risk
the President did the right thing and so
did the Supreme Court in this case yeah
I when I see that video of Nancy and
Chuck and Joe Biden and their their
immigration views from less than title
to use my fake eyelashes almost fell off
because I was rolling my eyes so hard
are you guys serious I mean it's on tape
this this is why we can't get anything
done with immigration because it's it's
a partisan issue it's not really based
on logic or reason or how each party
feels about something it's based on the
opposite position to take so that I can
run on this I can run a campaign on
whether people are so fed up I like to
think of myself as just a kind of a
typical normal American I'm an immigrant
as well I'm Canadian and I'm fed up
I just I don't have much more to give
and the thing is that that Chuck Schumer
tape that we played I mean in that same
speech I mean we could just run the
whole thing I mean another part of it is
really significant where he was talking
specifically about what you're talking
about the economic migrants and the
impact on on in low-wage migration and
how we've got to stop that because it
hurts American work right that's what
Schumer was saying exactly and he's
right on that but let's let's note that
elections have consequences in Donald
Trump and Mitch McConnell in the Senate
and Animal House guy we get frustrated
with the Senate but they are passing in
all the nominations of the president
putting them in places and the courts
matter and when they when they affirm
the President on the asylum law we're
not opposed to the race war you know you
know afraid for their lives coming into
America we just want an orderly a
process so if you come from Guatemala
and you get to Mexico you have to stop
in Mexico and you apply to get into our
country I was at the border as well and
people are coming through ports of entry
they're actually coming across rivers
and it's just a mad flood that's massive
country they're actually reading bells
and having Border Patrol come pick them
up and in different areas along the
border it's the most insane thing come
pick us up and get us you know a ride
over to Border Patrol station so if you
have a legitimate claim you're gonna be
and make that claim and you're gonna be
able to get into the country if you
don't you're gonna be turned back but
you mentioned walls as well the Democrat
convention is gonna be in Milwaukee
Wisconsin what do you think that
Democrats are going to build around that
convention yeah why not use that same
philosophy on our border build a wall
get a ticket to go into the country and
if you don't you get kicked we're gonna
be great wine great discussion thank you
all right